es ist krieg im netz am 31 dezember 2015
löst ein hacker angriff in der ukraine
einen großen stromausfall auf 700.000
menschen saßen im dunkeln und am 17
dezember 2016
die chance wieder diesmal waren nur rund
100.000 menschen im norden chaos
betroffen
doch der angewachsen schlimmer wie
sicherheits forscher und forscherinnen
der firma erst jetzt festgestellt haben
die schadsoftware ist so ausgeklügelt
dass die große industrieanlagen und
ganzer länder ausfallen kann im wahrsten
sinne gefordert sieht jetzt der große
cyberkrieg bevor sie zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
in deutschland wurde gar nicht darüber
berichtet ein stromausfall bei denen nur
100000 menschen der ukraine betroffen
waren
das ist keine nachricht entschieden die
redaktion doch jetzt ein halbes jahr
später stellt sich heraus
dieser angriff stellt wahrscheinlich die
größte gefahr für die gesamte industrie
weltweit ist so ausgeklügelt dass die
komplette stromnetze lahmlegen kann und
die vermutung liegt nahe dass es sich um
den angriff eines staates handelt was
sieht man nicht 100 prozent da sich
diese schadsoftware war
doch wer in ihr enthaltene zeitstempel
wie zehnter dezember und die
funktionsweise der schadsoftware wegen
des laz und sie ist auf diese anwendung
optimiert sie kann auf schalter und
überspannung sicherungen zu greifen und
sich steuern und das sind zum beispiel
geräte von herstellern wie siemens oder
abb die gar nicht gegen angriffe
geschützt sind
die schad-software braucht also nur den
zugriff auf das netzwerk zu erlangen und
kann dann nach lust und laune schalten
und walten
dafür schicken die angreifer infizierten
powerpoint-präsentationen einen
empfänger in diesem fall dem ukrainische
stromkonzernen krenn.ag und dort an das
umspannwerk nord über windows rechner
nimmt die win32 industrie getauchte
schadsoftware dann die kontrolle der
angegriffenen anlage kommuniziert über
das tor netzwerk mit einem command and
control server der angreifer und das
machen die angreifer außerhalb der
arbeitszeiten so dass es nicht auffällt
jetzt gibt es weitere komponenten die
die kontrolle von siemens die protect
geräten übernehmen sie sind außerdem in
der lage schalter auch mit hilfe einer
denial-of-service-attacke lahm zu legen
also eine attacke bei der so viele
anfragen an das gerät gestellt werden so
darf es nicht mehr antworten kann die
anlage ist lahmgelegt zudem ist die
schadsoftware fähig die windows rechner
überdies eingedrungen ist komplett zu
sperren in dem es für das system
wichtige dateien löscht und zudem lässt
es auch alle spuren hinterlassen
trotzdem wenn sicherheitsexperten jetzt
auf die schadsoftware gestoßen
das legt den verdacht nahe dass es sich
bei dem angriff um eine drohung an die
demonstrieren sollte was möglich ist und
es zeigt die macht dieser schadsoftware
monatelange wenig jahrelange
vorbereitung war nötig um sie zu
entwickeln und die angreifer mussten
auch über die zu steuernden industrie
komponenten verfügen um ihre steuerung
programmieren alles in allem liegt das
den verdacht dass es sich um einen
russischen cyberangriff der gruppe
zentrum handelt und er war viel
schlimmer als der angriff im dezember
2005 in er demonstrierte nämlich den
angriff auf infrastruktur können nämlich
umspannwerke lahmgelegt werden
dann können auch stromnetze ganzer
nationen ausgeschaltet werden damit es
wirklich ein neues level des fiber
krieges erreicht schon 2014 mutmaßlich
europäische regierungsorganisationen
unternehmen aus dem telekommunikations
und energiesektor und die nato an
auch damals wurde eine lücke in windows
betriebssysteme ausgenutzt 2014 handelte
sich um windows 8.1 und windows vista
sp2 jetzt aber ist der angriff sehr
ausgeklügelt und trifft eine so
empfindliche schwachstelle dass mit dem
schlimmsten gerechnet werden muss dem
umfassen angriff auf einen start
ein so umfassender stromausfall könnte
es zu unzähligen toten führen und
konzertiert mit einem konventionellen
angriff kann sich ein land kaum noch
wehren
es würde von den feindlichen truppen
überrannt werden dass alles in
zusammenhang mit denen von
amerikanischen sicherheitsbehörden
inzwischen als bewiesen an gewinnen
angriffen von russischen hackern auf die
usa
macht doch ein wenig ratlos wie geht es
weiter kommt der große cyberangriffe was
macht der westen was asien oder tobt im
hintergrund schon ein martialischer
treiber krieg den wir nicht mitbekommen
jetzt seid ihr dran ist der partner beim
fast food science dem wissenschaft
videowettbewerb und jetzt geht es los
mit super fahrt hier könnt ihr jetzt
ganz schnell gewinnen nämlich in 48
stunden wie das geht erfahrt ihr genau
hier einfach draufklicken wenn er mehr
wissen wollt es ist auf jeden fall ein
sensationeller wettbewerb ich würde mich
freuen wenn viele von euch dabei werden
also unbedingt drauf klicken ich halte
es wie du noch mal an
an gott gesagt bleibt